wait thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you yeah
you did a thing Thanks it's just a work
in progress but I think it's pretty good
I thought it was great is it so much
better than a nursing professor rich do
you just threw a cymbal at me
it's a tambourine okay so as
we're talking about music today we can
tell me where music comes it isn't the
too late guys
I would have come up with something
funny or if I had more time we were at
professor leaf miners class that guy is
amazing you know he speaks 40 different
ativ American languages yeah and he let
us go into his sweat lodge oh you mean a
sauna and anybody can make up languages
cuz you did the Bubba that's a language
anyway let's get back to music okay so
who can tell me where music comes from
professor leaf miner plays twenty three
instruments yeah and he's got this
eagle's claw in his man-bag he's the
greatest guy ever I'm gonna go over
there right now and suck his balls
yeah he's the crane check please
hi professor rich expert in science
these are my devoted students together
with the aid of harmless drugs we
explore Sciences greatest hypothetical
question
what if music dictates evolution
underline what does that mean is there
music which actually dictates how we
adapt and survive for example what if
the prevalence of Baroque music made us
more smart or rap music brought about
more violence what do you think
what's this aboard Native American
Studies or kick-ass peer cuts by prof.
Carmen lief mind let us be one with
coyote and roam the earth on our paws
what a dick
I had to examine the roots of music with
an expert who knew his how does the
brain affect music I mean you know the
music fake brain how does music affect
the brain you know what I mean
Wow okay your ear of course basically
filters out a bunch of vibrations and
produces a series of I guess in turr on
it you know impulses right like that
song I'm picking up good vibrations yeah
what kind of behavioral aspects to
certain types of music now well I mean I
think at a very primal level music with
a steady beat a regular steady beat
there's a phenomenon that yes like that
there's a phenomenon where we are it
appears predisposed to get in sync with
a regular beat you can think back to you
know working on the railroad right
you know I've been working on the live
long day I've been working on the
railroad just past the time when I can't
hear the whistle on though right it's a
song you sang while you were working on
the railroad what you were doing was
hammering spikes in and it needed to be
done rhythmically so if you're saying
that that primordial beat caused us to
work and sort of dictates our behavior
would you say that music actually
dictates our evolution oh I don't know I
mean most of the hypotheses go the other
way the music is what you might call
auditory cheesecake
we need food to survive but nobody needs
cheesecake to survive but um use against
cheese just cheese we all need a slice
of cheese I know I do before I go to bed
with a cheese
and Sitting Bull turned to the great
skies and said give me a home where the
buffalo roam it is the call of the
ancient Sioux when we ruled the earth
and played in the grass when we were
just - who said that I did professor
this isn't your class this is a
different class I'm sorry number one
I'll have you know I am 175th Chippewa
so let's dance the dance of the Buffalo
to talk I
he's fine just a few scratches no he's
dead
hey did you see Empire last night now
first of all I want to congratulate you
on being inducted into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame thank you do do you when
you look at deep purple now do you feel
that music has changed considerably I
think technically it's changed you know
from licious for instance take
Nickelback
look at those chaps yeah good okay done
so would you say in many respects that
music dictates evolution it won't change
evolution but I think it definitely has
some purpose glad to be a part of that
for me I was playing trombone nine and
ten years old I came home joy Paris pure
pants black-and-white TV the corner of
the room turn the TV on and I saw four
little chaps from Liverpool and I got
the trombone out playing guitars and
I've got the trombone I'm going it's
what if I hold it down here and that
moment unknowingly for me that was the
moment that the switch went on this is
even more special because you turned a
trombone into a guitar yeah and that's
magic is really gone I was gonna have
his baby
guys I'm real
what guys I'm really sorry about this I
guess if I would put it into a teaching
moment I'd say music dictated his
evolution and he didn't survive
professor while you're undergoing
psychiatric evaluation the class got
together and made this music video this
sort of just says how we feel that's
great let's have a look shall we
Wow that sucked
bye for now
there studies that have shown children
who grow up with mommy you're a good
mommy just don't let go